Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Before we dive into our conversation, I want to remind you that we love to hear from you. If you have any comments, questions, or ideas for us, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-R. Now on to the conversation. The spaces we are in every day influence our mood and well-being, whether we're aware of it or not. Creating spaces to make us feel our best is a hot topic in community planning in the office and on HGTV.
Here to talk about designing spaces to optimize well-being is APA fellow Dr. Sally Augustine, an environmental psychologist who is a principal at Design with Science, a design consultation firm. Welcome, Dr. Augustine. Nice to be here. So the start of 2019 brought us the Marie Kondo effect is what I'll be calling it. She's the famous Japanese professional organizer who's show on Netflix. Netflix called Tidying Up has been wildly popular. So Americans seem hungry for this type of program to show us how to declutter our lives and our homes. And as a design psychologist, what are
your thoughts on the response to the show? I think the response to the show indicates how burdened so many of us are by all the things in our physical environment. We have books, we have Chachis, we have all sorts of stuff that surround us and all those materials create an environment that's really very complex visually and when we're in a complicated visual environment, we feel stress. So I think the success of the Marie Kondo show indicates that people really, really need to tone back all the visual activity in the spaces that are around them. and they need to create a space that has about the same number of colors, shapes, patterns, et cetera, as they're likely to find in an interior designed by Frank Lloyd Wright.
Can you explain more why clutter makes us stressed? I mean, it seems like Americans tend to have too much stuff, and it makes us stressed. But giving it away and getting rid of it is difficult. So can you talk about why clutter, though, is still stressful for us? Clutter is stressful for us because whether you realize it or not, you're always surveying the environment around you. This is because our mental apparatus evolved millennia ago and we're still using the same sort of brain systems to assess our world now that we did in the past. So when we were young as a species, it was very important for us to be continually looking around. our world, making sure that nothing that found us tasty, was approaching. And when there's more
going on around us visually, it's harder to spot tigers, whatever, that might be lurking out there. So when we're in a space that's more complex visually, we get stressed out. Yeah, that's really interesting how it goes back so much further than just the current day, how it's a part of our biology. Yeah, it really is intriguing to think about all the vestiges of our primordial selves, if you will, that continue to be important in our world. And can you talk about your work you do at Design with Science? How did you get started? And what type of clients do you work with? Well, I have an MBA as well as a PhD. And I, I got involved in retail design projects as the sort of management type, if you will, when I
graduated from business school and was intrigued by how the physical environment in stores influence what people think and behave. That led me to go back to school to study environmental psychology and led me to my current practice where I work with people who are designing places or objects or services. And I make recommendations based on environmental psych research that make desired activities, outcomes, et cetera, more likely. So I will make suggestions about what colors, walls should be painted in order to enhance creative performance in a space or how ceiling heights come into play, how the textures we feel
make a difference in our lives. And I work with people all over the world to get environmental psych research out of all sorts of journals and into the world where it can make a difference in people's lives. It seems like more businesses and people are interested in designing good spaces today. Is that true or is that just, is it always been an interest? I think at one level, it's always been an interest, you know, since the, you know, first, you know, person tried to sell something to some other person, you know, they've been motivated to create an environment conducive to that. I have seen increased attention to applying environmental psychology in the last few years because people are becoming more aware that there is a science that can be used to design environments and make particular
outcomes and situations more likely. And now I want to get into more of the design details, how they influence us. Can you talk about how our motions are influenced by colors, patterns, lighting, and texture? Sure. I'll start with color. because this is what I'm asked about most frequently. Color has three attributes. There's hue, which is the name we give to a collection of wavelengths, and there's also saturation and brightness. Saturation is how true a color is.
So like a khaki green is less saturated than a kelly green. You also might think of saturation as how much. gray there is in a color with less saturated colors having a more gray component to them. And brightness is, you know, surprisingly enough exactly what it sounds like. It's really, you could think of it as how much white there is mixed into a color. So colors that are not very saturated, but are relatively bright, relax us. So like a sage green that has lots of white mixed into it, so it's a light color. Well, we would find relaxing to look at a
color like that, where a color that is more saturated but not as bright, something like say a Kelly green, well, we find that really energizing to experience. But there are a couple
hues that have very particular effects on us. Seeing all sorts of different greens makes it more likely that we'll think creatively. And seeing Reds, for example, degrades are analytical performance. Really? Just for starters. And there's a lot of other interesting research that we can talk about. For example, when people are sitting on a cushion of some sort, you can think of that
as a haptic experience, a touch-based experience. They are less likely to drive us hard a bargain as when they're sitting on a harder surface. When we smell a particular sense, even if they're very subtle and we've been being exposed to them for, and we've been exposed to them for a long time, well, they have significant influences on what goes on in our heads. For example, when we smell lavender, we are more likely to trust those who are nearby, and smelling lemon is likely to enhance our cognitive performance.
So, you know, we can work our way through the senses one by one and see how various different stimuli influence how we think and behave. And we can also think about more psychosocial type factors such as, you know, humans need for privacy, their need for control over their physical environment. You know, basically everything you can see here, feel, et cetera, around you has some influence on what goes on in your brain. What about patterns? Are there any particular patterns that are more, you may be jarring or upsetting than other patterns? or more soothing? Well, it's interesting to think about patterns because, you know, they're composed of different
shapes and colors and types of lines and things like that. And something that's really significant to consider when you're choosing a pattern for a place in your life is the relative number of curving lines versus the number of straight lines. And no pattern or place is entirely curvilinear. I mean, that seems like a cartoon. Or entirely rectilinear. A place that's all rectilinear makes you, well, that's like an awful spaceship horror movie type interior. So when we're exposed to relatively more curvy lines, we think a space is more
comfortable where when we're seeing mainly rectilinear lines, straight lines, meaning at right angles, for example, well, thoughts of efficiency come to mind. So, you know, these sorts of lines along with color, et cetera, are important considerations when patterns are being selected. Yeah, it's so fascinating that this is all happening really without us being cognizant of it, I think, for the most part. And lighting, too. I mean, for example, I like to don't really like fluorescent lighting and I use a lamp in my office. So lighting is an important component to me. Can you talk about what it means to other people and what lighting is beneficial, what lighting is difficult for people? Sure. When we're thinking about lighting, it's really important to align with whatever people are trying to accomplish
or what sort of experience people are trying to have in a space. So if you want to relax or think creatively, a warmer light can really work out well. And this would be no surprise to people because, you know, what do we do when we want to relax and hang out with people and have a good time? We tend to light a fire and, you know, bring out the candles, all of which produce warm light. But there's a time for cooler light. And cooler light is good when you're trying to do something a little more analytical. And also, you're also. Also, when you need to revere yourself up and give yourself a boost of energy. So, you know, if you are trying to work out, you want to turn on the lamps in, you know, whatever space you're working out in that have the cooler colored light bulbs in them.
And what about how to sound play into all this? So noisy spaces for some people can be really aggravating, but for other people, they can really thrive in a noisy environment. Sound has a lot of subjective elements to it. When we feel more positive about the people making the noise or the noise itself has good associations to us, we're less likely to be aggravated by it. But generally, we are distracted in workplaces and things like that. by conversations and particularly conversations that seem like they might have some relevance to our life. But we also never want to be in a space that's completely silent. I mean, you know,
first of all, it's impossible to create a space like that in everyday life. But also, that's just plain weird to us. That isn't where our ears and, you know, brains developed. You know, the spaces where we spent our early days, you know, wasn't, wasn't silent. There was always a little bit going on. And some interesting recent research indicate, or relatively recent research, indicates that hearing nature sounds, the sorts of sounds that you might hear in like a meadow on a lovely spring day, well, that is cognitively restorative to us. So, you know, if we've become mentally mentally exhausted doing work that requires concentration or focus, if we hear sounds like gently rustling leaves or a burbling brook, etc.
We can restock our mental processing power and also, you know, we become a little less stressed. And I want to go back to what you talked about before about scent and how important that is. I mean, it's pretty widely known that scent plays an important. part of memory recall, but how can sent be used to help us remember to be creative? And you said lemons play an important role. Can you elaborate on that a little bit more? Sure. Lemon is linked to enhanced creative performance. But there are two sorts of different related experiences. There are some that seem pretty universal, like the ones I was talking about
with lavender and trust and lemon and cognitive performance. But there are others that are unique to each individual. So, you know, if you had lovely conversations with family members on your grandmother's front porch and your grandmother cultivated all sorts of different kinds of honeysuckles or whatever or honeysuckle plants and they, you know, surrounded that porch, you'll have all sorts of positive associations to the scent of honeysuckle that are unique, you know, to you and your family. So, you know, we need to think about more general responses to sense as also, as well as more idiosyncratic ones. Is there a scent that can help us learn better?
Yeah, generally a scent such as a floral scent that is likely to be perceived as pleasant and boost our mood would be a good sort of odor to smell while we're learning new material. You know, anything that will boost our mood makes it more likely that we'll have. productive educational experiences, get along with others, etc. And how can a furniture be arranged to create a certain feel? I mean, this might be difficult because it's such a broad question, but if you're trying to create comfort, how can you arrange furniture? If you're trying to create more of an serious office environment, how can you arrange furniture?
Sure. When you're arranging furniture, you need to think about what's going to happen in the space and who's going to be there. For example, we've all had the experience of walking into a classroom and finding the chairs arranged in a circle, for example, or sitting at a roundish table where everybody can make a ready eye contact with each other. People generally are more likely to participate in a conversation, et cetera, when they can make eye contact with others.
but there are some cultural components to eye contact. And those of us who are raised in the West are a lot more into making eye contact and maintaining it than people who have grown up in other parts of the world. So if you're creating a space where people from many cultures are likely to be present, it can be a good idea to have some sort of low, like focal point, like flower arrangement in the middle of a table that people can gracefully divert their gaze to when they need an eye contact break from others. Also, we have to think about things like interpersonal spaces when we're arranging furniture.
You know, some of us, based on our culture, personality, et cetera, like to be closer to each other than others do. Also, personality influences the sorts of seats. people prefer, just as an example. People like me who are extroverted are a lot more positive about sharing a sofa, for example, with others than people who are introverted. So there are a lot of factors that go into furniture selection and where furniture is placed in an area. Yeah, it does really sound like it. And, you know, going from my own experience of home decorating, and it can be a challenge with how to make the space appear larger. I mean, you can use mirrors maybe to help. make a space larger?
Yeah, I mean, you know, one of the most straightforward ways to make a space seem larger is to paint the walls a lighter color. Walls that are a lighter color seem a little further away than they actually are, which is often a good thing. Very few of us live in homes or work in environments where the rooms are too big for us. Right. Yeah, most of the time you're trying to make it look bigger. but so it's probably not a good idea to paint the ceiling a dark color because it can probably
make it feel like your right if you paint the ceiling a dark color it does seem to move down on you that can really get to feeling oppressive so i watched this documentary a while ago called city in the sky about how airports design or design in such a way that allows people to find their way without signs and it's fascinating because a lot of these cute were all subconscious and subtle, but they worked. They directed people in a specific direction. So you talk about how that works. You know, humans have this tendency to always be looking through the world around them, and they also desire to move through spaces in particular ways. For example, those of us in the West, particularly who drive on the same side of the road that we do in
America tend to, you know, travel, you know, towards the right. We tend to keep going in a straight line unless there's something that diverts us. We tend to stay on the same material underfoot. So if we're walking on a carpeted path, a carpeted surface, we're unlikely to leave that carpeted surface unless we have a good reason to do so. And this kind of proclivity, if you will, among people can be used to design environments that make it more likely they'll travel to one space or another. There's other things that come into play as well.
Like we tend to walk towards bright lights or a window. This is another example of the way an environment can keep people moving. moving forward to a desired goal. Yeah, that's really, it's really fascinating just to think about all the things you just do take in as you're, you know, walking through a space that help you find your way, the wayfinding. Yeah, people are really cool. Our brains are really interesting. Yeah, they certainly are.
There's been a lot of talk about the open office concept being dead and really not working out for a lot of people. So what advice do you have for clients about creating an office space that allows for collaboration, creativity? but also also allows for privacy? Sure. The open office is really evolving from what people classically think of an open office to what's known as an activity-based workplace.
And in an activity-based workplace, there are a range of different sorts of spaces that people can use at different times. And activity-based workplaces really seem to work out, if you don't mind the pun, pretty well for users because when people are doing something that doesn't require quite as much, concentration or focus, they can hang out in a place like a sort of at-work lounge or coffee area, for example. But when they really need to concentrate, either alone or with others, they can move to another sort of space. So, you know, having flexibility in terms of
the environments available and the ability to control where we work is great for our performance, our mood. So all things good flow out of control. So having a hybrid, if you will, of like some places where you can have your privacy, but you can also have these open areas for collaboration is probably the best suggestion. Yeah. And that's what an activity-based workplace really is. It's a variety of different sorts of mini work environments all combined into one corporate or organizational area. And I want to go back to a concept you talked about in the beginning about how space can be designed to increase sales. So are stores set up in a particular way to motivate us to buy? Yeah. There's all sorts of things that happen in retail.
environments that encourage people to make purchases. For example, you know, color selection can be an important way to drive sales. You know, if you've got more of an impulse purchase type good, you make an environment a little more energizing if consideration. is required to select among goods available. You want the environment to be a little less energizing, for example. And all this gets down to really thinking about what sort of shopper you're dealing with. Some people are at particular points in time much more utilitarian focused in their shopping.
They have to buy milk and bread as quickly as possible. possible, get out of the store for whatever reason. And other people are more recreational type shoppers. You know, they're out on a Saturday afternoon with their friends. So, you know, you need to consider the shoppers and what their goals are when you're creating a work environment. I mean, you need to consider the shoppers and their goals when you're designing a retail environment. Is there a reason why typically at the end of the aisle there's those impulse-like purchases? A lot of times, you know, at the grocery stores, you see candy at a store like Bad Bath and Beyond, you see a bunch of little knick-knacks you probably don't need.
Maybe you do, but you see them as you're waiting in line. Is that just to subconsciously drive people to, you know, make those last-minute purchases before they go to the register? Well, those sorts of N-CAPs or at-register displays bring people, attention to those objects and make them really pertinent in ways that might not otherwise be the case. You know, if you're in a store, you might not travel down an entire aisle or even turn down an aisle. But, you know, often you can't help but walk by the NCAP and you certainly, you know, have to pass through some sort of, you know, register area in order. to leave the store. So, you know, placing impulse-type purchases in these areas makes shoppers
aware of them, you know, and particularly in a checkout area, it gives them the opportunity to consider these items while they're whiling away their time in line waiting to pay. And design is a big concept in urban planning, and so city planners and devaluing, are going toward a mixed use development type of style where you'll have just to describe it quickly you have a large building with say restaurant shops a gym on the bottom floors on the top floors you'll have condos or apartments is this a conscious effort by planners to try to address some of the loneliness and isolation people are feeling loneliness and isolation and countering loneliness and isolation are something that are topics that environmental psychologists think about you know all
the time and creating spaces that will have other people in them that individuals need to pass through or by can help to some extent to counter feelings of loneliness. So, you know, they're being implemented more frequently in our cities and elsewhere. And this is a new concept or is this a retooling of sorts of the planned community concept we saw in the last century? In many ways, it's a retooling of something that's even older. Hundreds of years ago, people often literally lived above the shop or the workshop, etc. So combining more commercial areas with more residential areas is something that's It's been important to us for a long time.
It's more resource efficient, for example, and just, you know, can streamline life. Yeah, it seems like there's a tendency now to bring people into a space, whereas I think in the past it was sort of like people wanting more space out in a suburban community, a larger home. But now it's people are wanting, especially in a city like Washington, D.C., where we are here, there's this tendency for people to want to be brought into those city centers again. Or even if you're out in a small another community, you still want an area that can be like the town square, if you will. Right. People are social and they need the opportunity to interact with others when they choose. And also, as we develop more tools, we need to spend less time doing some sort of, we might call them like, you know, life tasks. that we needed in the past. So in the, you know, years ago, decades ago, doing laundry was a much more difficult process.
Now, many of us have access to machines, and that frees up lots of time where we can engage in other activities that are meaningful to us. And often those other activities involve other people one way or another. And in your world, what is the attitude about the trends you're seeing in urban design and planning? Are they, is it successful? Is it something that's still being decided if it's successful? I think design and design research is always evolving and we're always learning and new things and also being confronted by new issues.
So I think we're effectively dealing with concerns such as loneliness, but we have challenges that remain that relate to things like equity. So we make some progress and other issues remain. And are there any basically overall design no-noes, if you will, that you could summarize for people if they're thinking about designing their home, an office space, that sort of thing? Something that people often don't consider are the nonverbal messages set by a space. And these are really important in terms of our stress levels, our quality of life, etc. For example, we like to live in a home that says the things about us that we value. So we like to have objects out that indicate like we're a sports person if we are proud of our ability to do different sports or we're concerned about our family if that's really important to us.
Also, in our workplace, for example, we do our best work in spaces that indicate that our employer respects us and the contribution we make to the organization. You know, an employing organization can indicate respect by doing things like giving people some control over there in environment and also really listening and understanding what employees do so that a space clearly aligns with what individuals and groups need to accomplish during the course of the day. So I think that we always need to be considering what a space is conveying symbolically, if you will, to users and making sure that those silent conversations are productive and positive. Yeah, absolutely. And you've also done interviews about how indoor plants can make us more creative. and I want to just to throw that in there. Two kind of last fun kind of questions for you.
So how does having a plant in your home make you more creative? Well, when you add green leafy plants to your home, your stress levels come down and you are more likely to think creatively. And there's probably several different factors that come into play. Plants are often green. as we were talking about before, green has been linked to, seeing the color green has been linked to enhanced creative performance. Also, green leafy plants tend to have curving stems,
and that indicates comfort and relaxes us to a certain extent. So, you know, having a few plants in a space is a good idea. You don't want to add too many. You don't want to create an indoor jungle, if you will, that really increases the visual complexity, something that we were talking about earlier. And the research indicates that the best results are found with green leafy plants as opposed to things such as cactuses. So, you know, the effort that's required to keep a ficus or some sort of plant like that alive is worth it from a psychological perspective.
And one last question for you. So you were interviewed for a sort of. story at the start of the year about how keeping Christmas lights up past the holidays, a little past the holidays, is good for our mental health. So you talk about why that is the case? Sure. I think that when people have positive associations to things such as Christmas lights, you know, they've had great experiences over the holidays in previous years, keeping the lights around for, you know, until they feel like they don't want them around anymore, can, give individuals a psychological boost. You know, part of the basic story that we're uncovering in environmental psychology is that people need to be true to themselves,
what makes them feel good, and to their humanness, their human attributes. And so having Christmas lights could be that if you're into the holiday spirit and seeing them in the, you know, early parts of the winter where the days are short and where it's cold, you know, it's cold and everything. Right. And right now we're just talking about the associations people may have to the Christmas lights, but you can also think about how the various colors of the lights may influence how people think and behave. For example, if lots of the lights are emitting a golden, warmer light,
You know, that can, you know, directly help people relax, feel comfortable, get along with others, et cetera, like we were talking about candles earlier. So this gives us a little excuse to me to keep them up a few weeks longer if you want. If you have, it's helping your well-being, it's okay. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Augustine. I really appreciate your time. I was glad to be able to spend the time with you. If you've been a longtime listener or are new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating. in iTunes, and if you have time, write a review. We'd really appreciate it. Also, as I mentioned
at the top of the show, we love to hear from you directly. So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas to share, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-Dorg. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.